hi my name is andreas and I'm a partner
development manager at Google Play in my
day-to-day job I work with the most
interesting mobile game developers in
North America and Europe there are many
familiar faces actually in here quite
exciting and I hope to help actually
developers on making the mobile games
business successful on Google Play hi my
name is Tobias I'm a partner development
manager based in London and working with
developers in Western Europe today at
the first session after the lunch break
we want to help you to promote your game
and and to grow your user base but
before talking about the key standards
for use user acquisition strategy we
would like to put this into context as
you heard earlier before the mobile
industry is growing and it's getting
more competitive as well they're more
than 10 million developers worldwide and
each year they publish more than 1
million apps and if you look on the
right side if you think about games the
lifecycle of games has shortened as well
over the past years in 2012 the average
game matured after a bit more than 150
weeks last year it was a bit less than
50 weeks so you have a competitive
market shorter life cycles and also
increasing production values and this
means you want to have your user
acquisition strategy as effective as
possible
today we will cover three key examples
for your user acquisition strategy first
I will talk about how you can better
understand your paid and organic traffic
then second Toby will show you how to
convert with effective channels and
third Toby and Andrew will talk about
how to engage users in a social platform
let me kick it off with understanding
your paid and organic traffic you can
find the conversion funnel in the Google
Play Developer console
conversion funnel shows you place your
visitors installers and buyers by
acquisition channel you can also see the
relevant conversion rates and you can
drill down on search keywords and UTM
track channels the better understand
where your users are coming from you can
also find a country breakdown of google
blaze conversion funnel you can drill
into performance in your key markets and
learn about underperforming markets if
you learned the store listing visitors
the installs conversion rate in a
specific market is below your
expectations you can take action and
improve improve the localized store
listing you can then launch a store
listing experiments to test your updated
store listing to get more game instance
however optimizing your business
strategy in isolation is not that
helpful
so let's look back at store listing
organic conversion rates how do you know
if your conversions are as good as they
can be
or your leaving actually an opportunity
on the table at Google IO we've
announced benchmarking against your
peers this feature is coming soon to
Google Play Developer console and you
are now able to understand how your
store listing conversion rate compares
to similar games first we are providing
an overall benchmark for your organic
users and then we also actually provide
a country breakdown that helps you to
understand how your game is actually
performing versus the benchmark in a
specific market if you understand that
your game is potentially underperforming
in a specific market you can actually
take action based on this insight so
here you can see one example and the
game is actually performing ok but it
could do better so you can actually
optimize the locally localization of the
store listing improve
the performance of it and get much
better results if you want to understand
users even better than what you've seen
actually in the conversion funnel in the
Play Store and in the developer console
you can actually use firebase analytics
it was touched upon actually earlier in
the presentation and firebase Analytics
for mobile there's a couple of things
for you so first it's actually entirely
free and it is unlimited you are able to
actually measure 500 different event
types and 25 key value pairs per event
you're also able to access unlimited
unsampled data through bigquery firebase
is very much user centric so you can
actually focus on users instead of
sessions and then you will also see
metrics that are meaningful for you as a
game developer so you will see actually
daily active user stats but you will
also see for example LTV stats that you
can use for optimization
I've just seen my colleague walking in
he will talk later a little bit more
about LTV optimization firebase helps
you to already get these stats and this
is full right baked in into the into
firebase firebase is also well
integrated with other Google products so
it is integrated with our ads product
with our notifications products and you
can easily target audiences that is
actually captured with firebase
analytics it is also very easy to
actually track any user acquisition
campaigns through any paid channels that
you have you can see here a couple of
partners that are integrated with
firebase and you can then actually
attribute your ad spend and you can
understand is it actually a good way to
invest in one of the channels or is it a
better way to actually invest in the
other channels and so by implementing
firebase you will actually get all of
this data and you can take action right
after that
so now we talked about how to understand
you're paid on organic traffic let's
move on and talk about how you can
convert with effective channels earlier
today
mark reference the number of insults on
google play last year we had 65 billion
installs and at the Playstore we match
the best users with the best content we
want personalized collections and offer
seasonal collections as well but the
vast majority of installs still comes
from search there are more than 1
billion users on Google Play in more
than 190 countries as you know already
and all these users search on Google com
their each month more than 100 billion
searches so you cannot only achieve
success by reaching the users on Google
calm but also on the Play Store let's
have a look at an example this is a
store listing of more in order and the
developer decided to do search ads on
Google com
that's something you might be familiar
with a user is searching for a strategy
game and both paid and organic results
are shown but also as you can see on the
right side you can do the same in a Play
Store
both organic and paid results are shown
so the best way of executing this
campaign is working with a tool who in
the audience has heard about the keyword
tool for Adwords ok some some people
have so if you're wondering what are the
best keywords for my play search ads
campaign we have a keyword tool which
helps you to get the right keywords for
your mobile game keywords are very
important to optimize your campaign day
by day and we encourage you to use this
tool to optimize your campaigns for the
Play Store so now you might ask yourself
ok now I go back home and try it out but
will that work well we have one example
here from Mario's the developers of top
11 I'm actually a big top 11 addict and
my team knows that but these guys use
the play search ads and they achieve a
higher 7-day
appoo 68% higher than other google
channels and also the place search ads
compared to google.com they were 59
percent lower in terms of the CPI so I
encourage you to try this out at home
don't forget the three best practices
one use the keyword tool to run target
CPA campaigns and ensure that the CPA is
lower than your lifetime value and last
but not least optimize the campaigns day
by day because with an advertising
campaign it's basically like with a
mobile game it's never finished so now
we talked about understanding your paid
on organic traffic converting these guys
with effective channels but the players
if they're not playing your game they're
actually on social platforms they are
talking about your game they're watching
videos about your game and the number
one social platforms for games is
YouTube ninety-five percent of all
gamers turn to YouTube for information
and entertainment gamers watch 144
billion minutes every month on YouTube
for live videos recorded videos and
streams so actually somebody calculated
that number now the real stars on
YouTube are the influencers who in the
audience has worked with YouTube
influencers before okay I see well a lot
of hands more than the keyword tool okay
all right um so please raise your hand
again if you were successful okay that's
quite good but I think we can increase
the conversion rate a bit more you see
some examples here in the slide so on
the top top right you see ksi that's the
one of the top youtubers in the UK 14.5
million subscribers
you see contractor very popular youtuber
in Germany ldshadowlady is the most
popular female gamer
on YouTube with more than 2.5 million
subscribers and last but not least
gamers and France turn to see phone o to
learn more about the latest games and
updates and let's play videos
so these are some examples but now you
might ask yourself okay what is the
right strategy what are the youtubers I
should be working with and how does
success look like so we thought we
should ask someone who knows the best
please welcome with me
Andrew salvo the CEO of seriously
hey there I'm Andrew stavos CEO and
co-founder at seriously we've got one
app currently out in the market called
best fiends and I'm going to talk a
little bit today about our marketing
strategy which is primarily focused on
YouTube and influencers and I'm also
going to share a little short video at
the end which shows how we are planning
on taking our work to the next level so
our approach is to build a brand we look
at the app that we have and the apps
that we have coming as the platform for
our intellectual property we think it's
a great opportunity right now with
everybody moving from traditional media
platforms to new devices obviously like
mobile tablets for entertainment brands
to be directly connected to their
audience one of the great challenges the
traditional media industry have is that
the IP is normally distributed on
someone else's platform other than the
creators and we thought by being
connected we might have an opportunity
to build out our IP in a big way we try
to be as creative in our marketing as we
are in our product development our apps
are about introducing a world and
characters and a story to the market and
when we were thinking about how we can
be super creative we knew that as a
small early-stage startup it would be
really really hard to compete with a
massive marketing budget of some of the
biggest players in the App Store's
and so we asked when we launched when we
launched best fiends coming up to two
years ago we asked the CMOS of most
mobile game companies what works for you
and everyone said Facebook Twitter great
acquisition platforms and we said what
doesn't work and they all said YouTube I
can't make YouTube work for acquisition
so we thought that we'd really focus
there
and over the last few months we've been
super focused on taking our approach on
youtubers upper level really focused on
us UK as kind of core markets for us and
we've had some really interesting
learnings so we'll share some of those
with you
our strategy is based on the app being a
live service so every two to three weeks
we update our app with some fun new
product features new content new levels
new characters enhance the experience
and we mirror the product update with
big marketing pushes we've actually got
one today on average we're looking to
hit somewhere between 70 and over 150
videos over a weekend that kind of help
promote our game today we're we've got
an update where we're introducing a
treasure hunt into our game it's a
really popular feature with our audience
where if you find 15 stickers that we've
hidden in the game you get to unlock a
new fiend Terry the tarantula you can
otherwise buy him for 10 dollars or you
can win him by finding all the stickers
in the next three weeks each of those
stickers comes from a famous YouTube
star and over the next few days these
youtubers including including Rachel
Levin Rosanna pansino are going to run a
video saying hey find my sticker in the
game and if you find all of them from
all these other youtube stars as well
you are not the character so it's really
nice to be able to kind of in to
integrate your marketing message with
the product itself so overall as a
company we've got two million daily
players but over the last three or four
months when we realized that we could
scale this up in the US we'd be making
some really nice progress and we're now
around 450,000 d au since we started
focusing on a big import
so strategy and if I look at our
progress that we've made we really kind
of shifted our da you from a year ago
and you can see that we've kind of
really started building our base in the
US which is now our biggest market so
here are some of the kind of key lessons
that we've learned from working with
influencers you know what I'd say is
this is what we've learned so far but
the markets always changing and now it's
getting more and more competitive I saw
like 80% of you have done work with
YouTube influencers I think the trick is
like take this but you've got to kind of
be more creative than what we've done
because the things always moving and I
think it's really really important to
try and outdo what you've done before so
the number one thing we kind of learn is
youtubers out our brands themselves
they're connected to their audience they
like working with other brands and if
you haven't got a brand vision for your
product you should really think about
that in terms of how you communicate
with the youtuber because that's what
will get them very excited the second
thing is most big brands as we know them
whether it's most big big brands tend to
be very very detailed about what they're
looking for for the youtuber to do or
say the reality is that doesn't work
you've got to let the youtuber be
authentic they've got to genuinely like
your product and if they don't I don't
think it's a good fit so it's really
important they like your product in
there and that you allow them to be very
authentic and when I say integrate back
in for maximum effect the example is
that treasure hunt today I think it's a
really nice way of kind of allowing them
to say hey I love you know I enjoy the
experience of playing the game or
playing you know playing the app and
there's a reason why you can find
something from me in there these guys
have amazingly close relationships with
their audience and they've got to feel
natural and authentic working with big
guys is great because it sets you up in
the marketplace and allows other
influencer
to come in and say oh I'd like to work
with you because chaos I work with you
I'll tell you a funny story about our
very very first experience working with
an influencer when we launched we work
with um we work with PewDiePie is like
our launch had a very small budget we
put most of it into a PewDiePie video
and we definitely learned some lessons
there but I'd say it's really important
to work with some of the big guys it
allows you to focus on some of the new
up-and-comers as well what I love about
YouTube is a platform and influencers
generally is that all of these view many
many of these views are occurring on
mobile so if you're trying to kind of
deliver nice acquisition and build your
business you always one click away from
a download and I think that's what makes
the platform so powerful and then you
know we've kind of we've tried loads of
things in our marketing we you know I
really encourage our team to think
creatively about trying new stuff that
we can learn from and what's incredible
about this platform is unlike say a
television buy or a one-day kind of
digital media activation the videos live
and you'll carry on doing views they
just kind of we go back to videos that
we did at the start this year and
they've added another half a million
views so it's not a ephemeral like
television so I think it's a really
really interesting platform to focus on
the other thing you get is you know you
really get you get a long tail you get
in theory an endorsement if the youtuber
likes your product but the other thing
you get as well in addition is media
value on top you reach a big audience
and it's you know for us as a company
that is valuing the brand that we're
trying to build and looking to build
value they're actually kind of putting
this out there you get to see that
you're even more effective across other
acquisition channels too so one of the
things we're starting to look at is how
this also helps with our retention as
well as acquisition you know it's really
important that if you are working with
an influencer you're up you know they
are upfront honest straightforward about
what you're doing there are certain
rules that you need to comply with in
different market
but at the end of the day the kind of
golden we're always just be
straightforward if you're paying an
influence so they need to make sure that
they do mention that very clearly so
today we're actually launching a video
that kind of takes the evolution of the
700 or so YouTube influence of videos
we've done and takes it to the next
level and really the way we kind of
think about it is is we've been building
our two million da you and 40-plus
million downloads on the back of other
people's influencer videos and that we
think that's a really nice strategy and
we're going to carry on working on that
but we wondered if there was a way that
we could kind of take that to a next
level so what we're launching today is a
scripted video that we've been working
very hard on for for quite a few months
now where we integrate traditional
Hollywood talent in this case Kate Walsh
from who was in the television show
Grey's Anatomy peak practice and appeals
to our core audience demographic of 25
to 45 year old women and marrying that
with two of the world's biggest YouTube
stars Rosanna pansino who's the work
who's the biggest kind of celebrity chef
on YouTube and Joey Graceffa who's very
very popular particularly within the
LGBT community and marrying those two
with a fun scripted video that has been
inspired by our fan base now I don't
know how many of you have played best
fiends but one of the things that our
community on social media tell us quite
a lot is actually don't download best
fiends it's kind of addictive and a few
people have said hey I'm totally
addictive sent me two best fiends rehab
so we were kind of inspired by that and
created a video to that effect so it's
cool it's it's two minutes and we'd like
to premiere it today
there is a contagious epidemic sweeping
the nation it's not just inner cities or
our workplaces or even our homes it's in
our hands it's taken over my life once
you start you can't stop
I don't know who I am anymore
most people think best fiends won't
happen to them but it's simply harmless
fun thought I could just try it once but
soon it becomes an obsession I wouldn't
say that I'm obsessed
I'm spirited passionate that's what's
going on here some people we can help
DOCSIS I may never use my thumb's again
you always think it'll happen to someone
else's family look what he did I Billy
others require more specialized
treatment
I have finally beaten level 256 I'm a
YouTube star
of course you are start by recognizing
the warning signs of tiredness gamers
thumbs night tears and sweaty eyes to
Quahog in just seconds anyone can be
playing best fiends after all it's free
to download from Google Play
it took me about a month to be done it
one click and you may have begun an
obsession
you can't stop okay well no I was just
talking about best fiends oh no no no
I'm a doctor oh of course you are miss
Moss let's get you back into bed dr.
Walsh
no I right now there is no cure for best
fiends my advice do not download best
fiends from google play not once not
ever the world will be better for it
worst case of best fiends I've ever seen
remember which used to be a doctor on TV
skew so yeah we look we're launching
that today we're promoting it in our
game and really trying to use our our
app as a platform to promote our video
as well and we're super excited about it
so thanks for watching
you